newly-released body cam video shows the
moments leading up to the deadly police
shooting of a black man who appeared to
be armed in Chicago 37 year-old Harith
Augustus apparently reached for a weapon
before an officer opened fire and killed
him several demonstrators were arrested
after violent confrontations with police
near the shooting scene on Saturday
night Dean Reynolds filed the report
from outside Chicago Police Headquarters
good morning police say they stopped 37
year-old harith Augustus when they
noticed a holster and a gun protruding
from his t-shirt and they say they
released the body cam video as quickly
as they did
to dispel misinformation that was
stoking tensions in the city in the
silent police video four officers
approached Harith Augustus on a
Southside Chicago sidewalk he pulls away
when one officer tries to grab his wrist
revealing what police say is a
semi-automatic weapon on his right hip
an officer opened fire when he appeared
to reach for a gun decision to use
lethal force is made in a split-second
and is based on the safety of the
officer and also that surrounding
community people who knew Augustus say
he worked as a barber and had a
five-year-old daughter people here angry
because this was a member of the
community he wasn't a bad person
demonstrators converge near the shooting
site Saturday throwing bottles and trash
jumping on a squad car and clashing with
officers who responded with batons there
were four arrests and some officers were
hurt yesterday dozens gathered again for
a March some protesters said Saturday's
incident was reminiscent of the deadly
police shooting of seventeen year-old
laQuan McDonald in 2014
McDonald was shot 16 times as he walked
away from police and was armed only with
a pocketknife police video of that
incident wasn't made public for more
than a year police say video of
Saturday's shooting shows a key
difference
this was not an unarmed individual the
individuals are
why he chose to do what he did I don't
know police recovered a gun and
ammunition from the scene of the
shooting they say that the suspect did
not have a permit to carry a concealed
weapon and as for the officer involved
in the shooting he's been on the police
force for less than two years and he's
now been assigned to desk duty for the
next 30 days pending an investigation
gale
all right Dean Reynolds thank you that's
why it's this video is so video this
video content is so important because
when you look at it as even as a
layperson
clearly look like he had a gun and that
he was reaching for the gun at the time
of the shooting all these cases are
different